Shackled to a wheelchair this is the
person at the center of an international
Manhunt entering a court here today the
end of the road which is tasked with
determining who he really
isn't it
he says he's Arthur Knight an Irish
citizen who's never stepped foot in
America U.S authorities claim he's
Nicholas Rossi a fugitive with a
colorful criminal record wanted for sex
charges someone who faked his own death
and went on the Run they want him
extradited the prosecution narrative is
that you are an alleged rapist a view
shared by American law enforcement who
claim he's a fraudster a dangerous
sexual predator something Sky News
questioned him about earlier this year
are you that man are you Nicholas Rossi
well I can relatively say that I am not
ever once done any of the acts as you
just discovered he was arrested in his
covert hospital bed in Glasgow last
Christmas tracked down after an Interpol
tip-off tattoos it's claimed the
giveaway
would you show us your arms I've shown
you your biceps yeah I would say okay I
am not getting him to this conversation
the conversation continued with its
first Witnesses including Glasgow
Hospital Medics Ruth Keating and Dr
Robert Hart
nurse Keating recalled the moment police
turned up at the hospital reception she
guided those officers acting under an
Interpol warrant to her patient's
bedside she was shown an array of images
of the man U.S authorities are looking
to track down and she said it was Arthur
Knight she cared for him three days a
week in hospital at that point and she
said his tattoos on his biceps were
distinctive the court he had also heard
from an expert witness in fingerprints
who said the fingerprints taken here in
Scotland matched those with Interpol
no response from a man whose fate whose
future Now lies in the hands of a single
sheriff in this Scottish Court
Connor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh